All right, so let's walk through this solution line
by line. We first initialize an empty array, word counts.
We then cycle through all of the lines in
the document. For each line in the document we create
an array, data. Data is the line stripped of
any surrounding white space and tokenized based on the white
space. For each string in data, we create a new
key. And we remove any punctuation from the word and
make sure that the word is lower cased. Then, we
check if the key exists as a key in word counts.
If it does, we add 1 to the value for
that key. If not, we initialize that key in the word
counts dictionary and we set it equal to 1. When
we've cycled through all of the lines And all of the
keys in each line. We print out the dictionary word_counts.
Which should have a count of each word, in our document.